Amen [ __ ] idiot rising we just cooked
all this [ __ ]
a snake [ __ ] both sets that goes you
two days straight yeah the party's
[ __ ] hungry yo I'm rich Brian
jouji and we're celebrating the a day
arising head in the clouds album and
tour by cooking for our friends that are
in a summer party house
the thing is though I don't think we
really know how to cook welcome to the
feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion alright so we're at the party
and it's finally happening we're about
to grill some [ __ ] and with it what the
[ __ ] is this judging well I've been
waiting for this moment i've been
waiting to feed y'all some real nasty
[ __ ] we got some snake we got some bull
testicles what the [ __ ] yeah well why
are you doing this to me yo G I'm doing
this to everybody I thought you didn't
like to cook I don't if we couldn't make
an army rice or sushi then we obviously
don't know how to [ __ ] grill bull
testicles so we're gonna need some help
from our chef here of Luther so if you
want to come on down here yeah take it
away - yeah great are you guys excited
I'm very excited I'm excited for the
rouse I'm the well you gotta fire them
right yeah but they're not that big do
you like I'll be honest
I've never cooked any of this stuff
alligator so it's the first time okay so
what do you what do you cook I cook
mostly different kinds of meats on my
food truck a joke I'll barbecue so we do
Chinese style barbecue but right we
typically don't go into the exotic so
I'm for me I'm excited to try this the
testes are quite creamy from what I
heard they look great yeah so you know
trying to get some textures in those so
being a bull and just like dying and
then just like watching over from heaven
just seeing your balls getting ghetto
about three [ __ ] dumbasses I'm
shooting a video so the party is already
going on we got to feed these people
they don't know that they're about to
bull testicle keep it on the down-low
let's get it three two one testes
[Music]
was the first move shoot I would love to
see the snake make its way onto the
grill there we go
all right is that just what it looks
like
like the testicle well I think there's
like the scrotum they usually you know
wraps around it and this is like I don't
think I'm tired
some octa-pie octa-pie yes you can just
go ahead and brush it oh [ __ ] so you're
pretty much just basting it with a
little bit of oil just cook it more
evenly okay with the heat and it also
helps with the coloration the mired um
and that's what provides the most flavor
you have all these grill marks I think
these testes are you can kind of see
there's a lot of bubbling in the back so
that it's a high water content type of
me these might take a while to grill
then you can go ahead and oil those
babies up do you want to go ahead and
grab some of those other meats alligator
yeah alligator down you can go ahead and
put that alligator right down in the
center yes sir okay
and from what I've what I know
alligators quite a lean meat so this is
they're gonna be the one that kind of
goes in and out quick okay yeah what's
the weirdest thing you cooked before
I've eaten some weird stuff turtle
dureena house turtle it's amazing they
had this big crock pot and there's just
a bunch of like turtle pieces in there
with a crazy aromatic broth and it's
just insanely delicious yeah reptiles
are slept on then when I was a kid I was
a super obsessed with Jurassic Park
and my dad would just like give me this
fish kind of dish and then he would like
lie to me and tell me that it's dinosaur
fish nice and and because of that I
would love it and all right be down to
eat it all the time well that's a good
dad right yeah because you know because
of that I got the protein that I needed
going right and now I'm five eight so it
looks like this is cooked through no
pinkness of the meat yeah and because
it's piles you kind of have to cook on
both sides but yeah I think it's gonna
be good
just to taste em and see what it tastes
like
[Music]
mmm pretty good huh it's really good
it's a very mild taste yeah that's like
nice yeah nice texture all right and
it's not seasoned at all not seasoned at
all so yeah we have some ground camo
right here chilies and some balls and
garlic when you're grilling outside if
you're doing a little backyard barbecue
we'll get together we want to make sure
that you're monitoring your your your
grill you know you can feel the
temperature of the grill right and you
can feel the hot spots there's certain
meats where you want it on the hot spot
for example these testes we want to get
rid of the moisture yeah I'm gonna cook
through so we're gonna put it on a hot
spot over here we have kind of like a
medium to medium hot spot this is where
these are slowly cooking you know I
think these will tend to dry because
there's not a lot of fat in there yeah
and then the octopus we want it on hot
we want a nice color the nice beautiful
crunch to it let's cut this guy open and
see and see what else
[Music]
all right I think maybe you need to cook
a little more it's a possibility
you want to try one no let's cook it a
little bit more I'm gonna try a little
bit you know I'm gonna be a trooper to
how much I really do if you guys are
trying it then I'm I have to try it yeah
that's all let's all go for that all
right
one for the team one for the team Cheers
I didn't think being in the music
industry would lead me to this place but
here we go oh it tastes good no shaking
hearts yeah yeah you guys your power
term on point
oh thank you
[Music]
all right so I'm I'm thinking these octo
we're gonna in do me sauce them Oh what
do you guys think I'm dying
that's a good idea okay that is
beautiful that looks yeah that's gonna
battle got some real barbecue you wanna
you want to solve a it oh I'm down so
that it's pretty much the packet that's
using a kit and we just pull that out
alright yeah go ahead
beautiful and go heavy with it this
octopus is not seasoned so okay let's
try the alligator oh yeah
don't you want to go ahead and grab this
off so this is seasoned with my food
truck
chicken seasoning okay so it's more like
a citron style seasoning oh and yeah I'm
gonna have your delicious wow that is so
that is so good Wow these things eat
children round and they taste amazing
oh now wait now payback dear this is
[ __ ] tight el fna alright so we're
kicking all these food and it's all
looking amazing but I don't know Jose
yeah I feel like we should call the boss
man out here and she call Shawn yeah we
need a good taste test there Shawn Shawn
[Music]
sup boys I don't die hey Don
so you made as you know kind of like
take care of all the food for the party
alright so I need you to try the bull
testicles okay
hey you down with that actually you
don't even answer that they're gonna
have to okay but are you guys gonna
partake with yeah how's it it's amazing
see I wouldn't I would find it very
rubbery if I just imagined it is it
rubbery it's very salty like chicken or
does it have fluid in it it doesn't
really like burst or anything okay like
you would think yeah so we you know you
grilled this whole thing and me and Joe
G have been like preparing for the food
for this party for like such a long time
but I got one last question for you man
are you proud of us
credibly proud man this [ __ ] looks
vibrant juicy tender exploding with
flavor I mean I can't wait to taste some
of this stuff but now the I Els you man
I'm gonna buy some homies in here I'm
your agent so we're down to you whatever
[Music]
serious let's choose what is this bro
that's Lynch Icahn you just got the
normal [ __ ] with it this one the
Gator is actually not bad
it's Gators but not gamey I know that
sounds like break it like that's holy
point I thought it was gonna be like
fish but it is definitely not it's just
literally just like chicken
it does knowing this is a count was
[ __ ] me up a little bit this again is
that really count emotionally or is this
anything like this you eat it and don't
use it to or not
oh not at all the two Asian people would
just eat like vinegar and you're like oh
yeah we fish fillets that looks like
some [ __ ] off of [ __ ] spread it away
or something Wow it does right get-get
up close on this dude what is this
chicken goddamn dude thank you guys for
trying this with me get on first time
cooking this dog well down to
experimental yeah the cam will [ __ ] me
up a little bit let me let me get a beer
that well I'm Josie I'm rich Brian and
we were eating some some [ __ ]
yeah shout out shout out to the clouds
album is out now shout out the first we
feast yeah and we got to get all this
food to all the people in the party and
they're hungry they are there hug their
way in there's a good way for that croc
yeah so thank you for watching all six
episodes and yeah man
[Music]
[Music]
Tim I Tyler take your clothes off one
more time maybe I can let you don't be
calling and impressing me then kind of
see your brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got history
when you look at me they can't
could I happy know what could a bit
finally your face I know it I decide you
see take my time to take your clothes
off one more time maybe I can let you
don't be calling and impressing me
see you care for me like a dress but you
fit better and wrinkled tea we moved
under new
the big history
[Music]
[Applause]